je suis sans voix
j'ai un sentiment d'honneur écrasant
mais aussi
un sens des responsabilités
[Musique]
je suis totalement convaincu
que
vous savez que
la qualité que tout le monde mérite qualité
peu importe si vous êtes pauvre
ou riche et ce sont toutes mes
idées  comment je peux créer du confort même pour
les plus pauvres,
donc si vous reliez cela à la
justice sociale, je suis honoré de l'entendre, mais
pour moi, cela fait partie de mon ADN
[Musique]
donc je voulais étudier une technique que je
peux simplement connecter avec
les connaissances traditionnelles  dans mon village natal ou dans mon
pays pour créer une école pour mon peuple
donc
c'était un devoir envers mon peuple
tu sais
parce que je voulais contribuer en
tant que membre de cette communauté au
développement de cette communauté
[Musique]
je ne sais pas  quelle sera la réaction
en afrique
mais quelque chose est sûr que
nous avons beaucoup de
jeunes à la recherche d'
opportunités
et que je vois l'
un d'eux
que je suis toujours en train de
gagner
le prix prisca
peut-être une grande ouverture tu sais peut-être  une
grande inspiration
pour devenir architecte tu sais
ouais